[Music]
when our vegetarian ancestors started
eating meat around 2 million years ago
it wasn't just because animals taste
great it was pure necessity
climate change made many of the plants
our ancestors relied on
less available and meet bridge that gab
from the discovery of fire at the latest
meat became a staple of the human diet
but over the last few years eating meat
has increasingly been associated with
health risks like heart disease
certain cancers and an early death
so how unhealthy is meat really
in this video we'll only talk about meat
dairy products deserve a video of their
own
biologically we need to eat for three
reasons for energy
to acquire materials to fabricate our
cells and to get special molecules that
our bodies can't make themselves
the energy and most of the materials
come from the three macronutrients fats
carbohydrates and proteins proteins are
the most important
resource for repairing and replenishing
our cell structures
the special molecules are a large
variety of vitamins and minerals
we need to drive metabolic processes
meat provides us with most of these
things it contains all essential amino
acids our body needs
and a lot of minerals like iron zinc and
essential vitamins
some of which are barely found in plants
like vitamin b12
only one essential nutrient is missing
in most of the meat we consume
vitamin c it appears in almost all
plants
and supports our immune system as well
as the development of connective tissues
after a few months without it you'd get
scurvy
but meat has another big advantage it's
high bioavailability
some of the nutrients in meat are broken
down faster and available quicker than
those from plants
spinach for example contains more iron
than meat but it's absorbed much slower
and the body needs more energy to digest
it
several health benefits have also been
observed in communities that rely solely
on meat
the inuit for example are able to
survive in extreme climate
conditions on a purely meat-based diet
if necessary
since they consume the whole animal
including the organs they get every
single nutrient they need
including vitamin c so meat itself
is definitely not dangerous for us but
its health effects vary
depending on how it's prepared and what
animal it comes from
when talking about meat in the western
world we generally mean muscle tissues
that have a high nutrient density but
also lack some of the vitamins that make
it possible to survive on meat alone
the most healthy animals to eat are
probably fish
fish contains polyunsaturated fatty
acids like omega-3
which may lower the risk of
cardiovascular diseases and support
anti-inflammatory immune functions as
part of a balanced diet
fish can be eaten regularly without
worries
eating fish comes with its own bag of
complications though
like overfishing and the destruction of
the oceans
we'll talk about that in another video a
close second
is the most popular meat chicken it's
regarded as the meat with the fewest
health risks
the only negative health effect of
poultry is a bit controversial
fat its high content of saturated fats
is associated with a higher cholesterol
level and cardiovascular disease
but this idea has also been criticized
by a large number of scientists
arguing high cholesterol levels might be
inherited and not caused by nutrition
so in general if you want meat and are
concerned about your health
go for chicken things start to get
problematic with high intakes of red
meat like beef
veal pork lamb horse and goat
a recently published study recommends
for example a maximum of 23 grams of red
meat per day
which is a very small steak per week
however large-scale meta-analysis
studies have shown that eating 100 grams
of red meat
every day increases the relative risk of
diabetes by 19 percent
of strokes by 11 and of colorectal
cancer
by 17 this sounds
alarming but before we panic let's have
a look at how these studies were
conducted
because this brings us to the second big
problem when trying to answer the
question of whether meat is unhealthy or
not
most studies that linked health risks to
eating red meat were case control
studies
which means taking a group of people
with a disease and classifying them
by their eating habits the more red meat
they consume
the more likely they were to contract
certain diseases
the problem is that it's very hard to
eliminate other factors
people who eat less meat tend to live a
healthier lifestyle
in general they tend to eat more
vegetables and fruit
and are less likely to smoke and drink
alcohol
most studies try to eliminate these
factors but it's extremely hard to make
definitive statements
things get worse when we look at
processed meat though
processing meat means adding certain
chemicals by curing
smoking salting or fermenting or in
other words
making it delicious bacon ham salami
sausages and hot dogs
contain chemicals that are harmful for
us like nitrates and nitrites
that can damage the dna in our digestive
system and lead to cancer
the who reviewed 800 studies over 20
years
and concluded that processed meat is
strongly linked to an increased risk of
colorectal cancer
each extra 50 grams of processed meat
per day
increases your relative risk of cancer
by 18
when it comes to cancer risk processed
meat is now in the same category as
plutonium
asbestos and smoking the who highlights
that its research
is only about the question of whether or
not something causes cancer
and not to what extent but processed
meat may also significantly increase the
chance of suffering from diabetes
strokes and coronary heart diseases
it also makes a difference what sort of
life our meat lived when it was still
part of a living being
it's common to feed large amounts of
antibiotics to livestock
in order to prevent diseases which can
spread antibiotic resistance
combined a high consumption of both red
and processed meat
could increase your chance of premature
death by up to 29
this means if your chance of dying is
three percent this year
it's now four percent this might not
sound like a lot
but tiny percentages have a huge impact
on societies of millions
they also seem harmless until they
affect you
to blame meat alone for bad health would
be wrong though
there is no evidence that the very
essence of meat has any negative effect
beyond its high fat content
and even this point is highly
contentious
just like with many other pleasures in
life sometimes
too much of a good thing is harmful most
public health agencies suggest cutting
meat consumption to 500 grams a week
while studies suggest cutting down
processed meat as much as possible
so if you feast on meat no more than
once or twice a week
you should be good for most people this
already means a drastic change in their
diets though
the average american consumes around
almost 1
600 grams of meat a week the average
german 1
100 grams a week and many of us eat much
much more if you're not really sure make
a small note whenever you eat meat
for a week or two you'll be surprised
how much it really is
so most people watching this video would
benefit from cutting down on meat
aside from health concerns there's still
the fact that the meat industry is one
of the largest contributors to climate
change
and has reached a scale where it's
impossible to deliver millions of tons
of meat
and still treat animals with dignity
we've already discussed that in detail
in another video all in all in
moderation
meat is not unhealthy and you don't need
to become vegetarian overnight to have a
real impact on your health
and the planet but your lifestyle
choices do matter
for yourself and for others
the key is being open to trying
something new once in a while
maybe you'll discover your new favorite
dish until you try
you'll never know what you'll enjoy or
what you're capable of
maybe after watching hours of kotzkazak
videos you've decided you'd like to
learn how to animate
now you might not know this but most of
our team actually has a graphic design
background
learning about design principles first
before we got into animation
was really key to where we are today
there's a really great new skillshare
class on using adobe illustrator the
software we use to create artwork
by graphic designer aaron draplin and we
can personally recommend it
it's full of great tips to help
understand and simplify a very
complicated program
if you want to do more afterwards we
have three animation courses of our own
on skillshare too
skillshare offers over 25 000 classes on
topics like film and video editing
writing design and technology from an
array of skilled experts
with the premium membership you can
access all of them for only ten dollars
a month
and as a bonus the first one thousand
cutscent viewers to use the link in the
description
will get their first two months of
skillshare for free
you